- My next guest is an awesome
and talented young woman, very talented.
We watched her grow up
on the Disney channel
and you saw her earlier
this year, along with me,
in the Netflix film "Feel
the Beat," which I loved.
She's about to come out with new music,
as well as a new movie called "Songbird."
Please welcome Sofia Carson, y'all.
(audience cheering)
(relaxed upbeat music)
- Hi, guys.
- Oh my gosh.
So sorry it's awkward.
- No, I wanna say I'm so happy to be here.
- I know, I'm glad we've
met already to where
I've already hugged you
and said hi and everything.
This would've broken my heart.
But I met you a long time ago.
- [Sofia] A long time ago.
- Yes, and was it with
Cameron at the time?
- [Sofia] Cam.
- Yes, that's what I thought.
It was with Cameron.
- Yeah, backstage.
- Yes, and I literally,
I knew that y'all were so talented then,
but I had no idea what
a triple, quadruple,
all the threats you are.
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] You're so gifted.
- Thank you, Kelly.
I mean, coming from you,
and I remember that night
so vividly at Disney World backstage
of one of the ABC Christmas specials.
And you were like imparting
your wisdom on us,
but like in such a cool way and me
and Cam were like freaking out.
- I always tell young people,
I'm like, "Please enjoy it
and then remember it."
- That's exactly what you said.
- Yeah, I'm like, we always just rush
right through it sometimes
and you're not present.
We don't--
- [Sofia] Enjoy the ride.
- We're always worried about
the next job or the next thing
instead of enjoying like
right where we're at.
But anyway, you were so
great in "Feel the Beat."
If y'all didn't see "Feel
the Beat" on Netflix,
you should check it out.
I loved it, it was so cute.
I honestly watched it
'Cause my kids were like,
"I wanna watch this," my
little girl and I was like,
I ended up loving it
like just as much as her.
I was like,
"This is so great."
- Thank you.
That means so much to me.
- I had to tweet about it.
Anyway, I loved it and
I don't generally tweet
about everything like that, but--
- You tweeted and I
almost had a heart attack.
It was one of those moments
in life where it's like,
"Oh my gosh, Kelly Clarkson is
watching my movie on Netflix
"and she tweeted about it."
I was like, "What is happening?"
And I screenshot it, sent it to my mom
and my whole family and
everybody was freaking out.
And you were just so
generous with what you said,
so thank you.
- Well, literally,
I was watching the whole thing going,
"Oh my gosh, the rehearsals
this must've taken,
"the discipline," like it's crazy.
But we were also both at the VMAs, right?
- We had the trailers next to each other.
- [Kelly] I did not know that.
- Literally, I saw your
trailer right there
and I was like, "Oh, so
close, but so far away."
- 'Cause, well, it was
weird because I walked in
and not a soul was in there.
- No, but they were being
super safe, which was amazing,
so I didn't see anyone.
I saw Machine Gun Kelly
from like across the room
and he's like very tall,
so he was hard to miss,
but yeah, I didn't see you.
- I am not tall.
You can definitely miss me.
(laughs)
(laughing)
So you've been singing a long time,
but what was the first song you learned?
- The first song I learned
was actually "Don't Cry for Me Argentina."
- That is super random.
(laughs)
- Super random
and super dramatic.
Like for three, you're right.
It's very random.
Yeah, I don't know why.
Oh, there it is.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [Sofia] That's my sister
eating her popsicle,
super disinterested and me
just having my own little drama
performance.
- Look at you.
Look it, shake it.
(laughs)
- That was like my outfit, the
bandana and my mom's heels.
I felt like in that,
that was right for me.
- I have kids around that
age, so it's cute to see,
"Oh, one day they're gonna look like you."
That's crazy, they're gonna be grown up.
I just got sad.
So tell me, I want them
to stay little forever.
So tell me about your new single.
It's "I Guess I'm a Liar?"
- Yes, "Guess I'm a Liar."
It's actually so cool
to be talking about it.
This song, well you're an
incredible musician yourself
and for me, it's always
been about the stories
that we get to tell and this
story is a story of survival.
It's kind of what happens after
your heart's been shattered
into a million pieces and
you're undeniably sure
that you can't live without him
and then you wake up one day
and you realize that you're
alive and you're choosing
to love yourself better than he ever did.
So guess I was a liar when I said
that I couldn't live without you.
- I love that.
I love the twist on it.
That was my favorite part of it.
So you've also got a new movie,
"Songbird."
- I do.
- You are constantly working, girl.
- Thank you.
- Okay, so how did you
do all of this in a pandemic?
- I'm so grateful.
I was able to shoot the first movie ever
to be shot during a global
pandemic, which is incredible.
And I remember recently
I came home from work
and there was a package at the door,
which we know is really exciting right now
when we get packages.
- It's like Christmas.
- And it was from our
producers, from Michael Bay
and my director, Adam Mason,
and it was a T-shirt with
the first slate of the movie
and they said that this
slate will go down in history
as the first film to ever
be shot during a pandemic,
so it's incredible.
I feel so honored.
- Wow, and speaking of all of this,
also on a really cool human note,
you're now a new, you're an
ambassador for UNICEF, right?
- For UNICEF, yes.
- Yeah, that's great.
So how did that come about
and what exactly does that entail?
Does it kind of happen
after you're allowed
to start traveling again?
- Yes, well, I've been supporting
UNICEF for a few years now
and this also goes back to my mom.
When I was young, she always
kind of instilled in us
that the most important
thing that we can to
is to give back.
And she would always
refer to Audrey Hepburn,
who was the first UNICEF
ambassador and who was my icon.
And now to be, to join
those ranks and to be able
to be a UNICEF ambassador
is the most important
thing that I'll ever do
and I'm so honored and
it basically means yes,
I do get to go on field trips
and I once traveled to Brazil with them
and I see firsthand like the
schools that they're building.
The girls that they actually
save through education,
which is kind of like where my heart lies
and I'm just so thrilled to see
where this journey will take us.
- Me as well.
I think it's really key
too 'cause right now,
'cause I have kids and
my mom was a teacher,
and education is so important
and we take it for granted
in this country.
- Because we don't
have to think about it.
- How it's offered
because we don't think about
it and now that our kids are,
my kids are dying to go to school.
- [Sofia] How beautiful is that?
My little boy's actually able to go,
but my little girl's dying
to physically be in school.
- Because they know what
it's like to not have it.
- 'Cause now they know what
it's like to not have that
and it's been kind of taken away,
but well, Sofia's new single, y'all.
"I Guess I'm a Liar" is out right now.
Y'all gotta check it
and be sure to check out
her new movie "Songbird" in theaters soon
'cause she has all the
projects going on, y'all.